Excuse me, big man,
big man, big man?
Excuse me, big man, though.
But big man.
Okay, God bless you.
I'll catch you on the up flip.
Thank you, big man.
[chuckles]
- Hey, brother.
- Hey.
Can I ask you a question
real quick though, brother man?
Oh, see, that's good
'cause I was about
to ask you a question
right quick.
Okay, so here's the deal, man.
Crazy thing.
My car ran out of gas
about a mile up the road.
That's why I was wondering if I
could get a little bit of money,
you know, just get
a couple of gallons.
Oh, that's crazy,
'cause you know what?
This--my car had also broke
down right up the road.
I got my daughter here.
She five.
- Okay--oh, oh.
- She sleeping in the car.
I got to get
back to her real quick.
- Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
- So if you could help me out.
Pssh, I was gonna ask you
if you could help me.
Oh--oh, okay.
Let me just give you my wallet
out here and show you my ID
to let you know that I
am straight up legits real.
I ain't trying--trying
to do nothing to nobody, okay.
Okay, on the issue
of legitimacy,
- I too have an identification.
- Okay.
That's a employee ID
from Borders bookstore.
You see right here,
I got my Bally's
Total Fitness ID
right there.
Okay, okay.
Shows you that I stay fit
and conscientious and whatnot.
You'll also notice that these
other IDs I have in my hand
have the same name on it,
which makes you know
that it is indeed me.
Right there, okay.
Okay, I too have multiple IDs,
crescendoing in this.
Dun da-da da.
Yogurtland punch card.
Okay, yeah,
I see that right there.
You see that right there.
That is almost my ninth
purchase, apparently,
and you can't fake that.
You get a free ten ounce
yogurt for that.
- Yeah, all right.
- All right.
So normally I would not ask
another person for assistance,
but our--our--our family is
in a fiduciary crisis right now.
Yeah.
My wife is languishing
in the hospital.
She a construction worker,
and what happened is
she got struck in the face
by a power line.
Fried her whole head up.
Burnt both her eyeballs out.
She's getting eyeball
replacement surgery as we speak.
Oh, see, I also have
a spousal injury crisis
on my midst as well.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm,
mm-hmm.
My wife was in
the astronaut program,
making her a full-fledged
astronaut.
Okay, impressive.
And she had gotten moon dust
in her lungs.
Inhaled, you don't
wanna get--
That's never good.
It's never good.
- You don't want that.
- Nah, nah.
So maybe we could find a ATM
or something like that.
Okay, so where--yeah,
perhaps if you--
Oh, look, that's one
over there.
- Oh, my gosh.
- That's a ATM.
What's--what's
the chances of it?
Let's go to that ATM.
We should probably
check that out.
Yeah, let's just take
a look right there.
Oh, stay with me, brother.
- Here we are.
- Why, here we are.
ATM machines that I did not know
previously were here.
All right.
Two of them, no less.
I'll tell you what we
should do, though, man.
- All right.
- You give me the $20, okay.
Yeah.
I'll give you the $3
that's on my person.
Yes?
Then I will give you
the $17 after.
Then you give me that $17.
I'll cut you a check
for $100 just to cover that.
You give me the change
in cash.
- Okay, okay, I feel that.
- Why am I playing?
I'm just gonna give you my ATM
card so you know I'm legit.
Sure, sure.
Of course, of course.
I'm gonna give you
my ATM card so we both
have something of value
from the other person.
All right.
And your code is?
It is 1...234.
And yours, sir?
- 1235.
- Thank you.
[ATMs buzzing and beeping]
Could that--that is
a Ralph's rewards card.
Okay, that is a credit
card placeholder
you would find in a translucent
sleeve in a brand new wallet.
- Hey, excuse me, big man.
- Hey, big man?
Big man?
- Hey, right quick, right quick.
Can I ask you a question,
biggest of men?
I got a question
right quick.